Justin Bieber is sky high with  transformers actress Nicola Peltz cue  the romance rumors that are now in full  swing thanks to a fan capturing their  cutesy and tower moment over the weekend  the to hit the towers famous glass floor  then of course Bieber PO need up the  extra cash to take Nicola fourteen  hundred and sixty seven feet in the air  up to the sky pod this is the second  time we spotted the couple who were  recently on a romantic dinner date in LA  on May twenty-fifth right now Nicola is  in the six filming her latest movie our  house posting this instagram photo with  the caption Toronto and sources say the  relationship is getting serious I mean  Justin did live from Winnipeg to Toronto  Saturday night had the date sunday then  flew to Calgary for his tour on Monday  not bad JB not bad at all